it was a day that both sides were
prepared for
police protecting the parliament waiting
for anti-government protesters
determined for their calls for
constitutional reform
to be heard
to break through the police barricades
the protesters were met
with jess after jet from water cannons
and tear gas
as the police were given rifles and
rubber bullets
that they said they were prepared to use
if there is
a need to do so we will need to do and
there are step to to be taken
uh we've got to take the steps very
strictly
at courses according to the law here but
before we enforce
the law uh we make sure that the uh we
do the ghost suv then first
[Applause]
on the other side of parliament police
quickly melted away
and then the real battle began
[Applause]
protesters who've dared to question the
power of the monarchy
royalists who believe the role of the
royal family should never be discussed
the two sides coming face to face after
months of rival protests
paving stones rocks and bottles missiles
flew through the air well this is now
descended into a complete street battle
the anti-government protesters moved
down this street over here
the police withdrew down there and now
completely out of sight
and there are pro-royalists who are here
waiting with barricades dismantled the
protesters advanced on parliament
again forcing the police back i'm so
disappointed what the police do to us
because it's unfair they treat a yellow
shirt via
another way they treat them better than
us
waves of water cannon didn't stop them
pushing through
to the gates of parliament what have
been months of largely peaceful protests
no longer seem to be tony chang sky news
bangkok